[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Anne
gellineck guten Abend es war eine
erleichterte SPD die Olaf Scholz heute
Vormittag nach dessen Parteitagsrede
stehend
applaudierte ter weil der Kanzler nicht
den spröden scholzomaten gab wie sonst
schon mal für seine Verhältnisse fast
emotional bespielte Scholz die gesamte
Klaviatur sozialdemokratischer
Lieblingsthemen der Sozialstaat eine
Errungenschaft die bewahrt werden muss
die SPD Partei der arbeitenden Menschen
gegen Rechtsextremismus setzt er Anstand
und Zuversicht ach so und für den
Haushalt findet der Kanzler auch bald
eine Lösung konkreter wurde es
allerdings nicht Lars bohsack aus
Berlin stehende Ovationen für den
Bundeskanzler nach einer 50minütigen
Rede die seit Tagen hohe Erwartungen
gesetzt worden waren würde es Olaf
Scholz schaffen seine Partei mitzunehmen
gar aufzubauen ganz offenbar auch mit
schmeichelein wer ein bisschen in den
Geschichtsbüchern dieser Republik
blättert der wird feststellen eine so
gute abgestimmte solidarische
Kooperation zwischen den ganzen
Strukturen der Sozialdemokratischen
Partei das haben wir selten so gut
geschafft danke dafür das ist die
Grundlage für die Kraft die wir für die
Zukunft brauchen doch diese
Geschlossenheit hatte in letzter Zeit
Brüche bekommen die umfragezahlen der
SPD sind miserabel die des Kanzlers noch
mehr und über allem schwebt dann noch
die Haushaltskrise die mittlerweile eine
veritable Regierungskrise ist eine Angst
nimmt Scholz seinen Genossen es wird in
einer solchen Situation keinen Abbau des
Sozialstaats in Deutschland geben die
SPD schärft ihr soziales Profil und der
Kanzler zieht mit Forderungen der Union
aber auch des eigenen Koalitionspartners
FDP das Bürgergeld zu beschneiden
erteilt Scholz eine klare
Absage ein Gesetz dass der Deutsche
Bundestag beschlossen hat mit den
Stimmen der CDU CSU ein Gesetz das der
Bundesrat gebilligt hat in dem eine
Formel drin steht
gesetzeskonform durchzusetzen ist ist
ein Gesetz das für sich eine ganz Große
legitimationswirkung hat und man muss in
solchen Situationen auch mal
wiederstehen mit seinen Ansagen dürfte
Scholz die Verhandlungen über den
Haushalt mit FDP und grünne nicht
leichter gemacht haben seine Partei
allerdings hat er damit hinter sich
geschart es war eine sozialdemokratische
Rede eines sozialdemokratischen Kanzlers
er hat klare Worte gefunden ich glaube
das hat man auch hier im Saal bei den
gemerkt er hat viele Themen angesprochen
die uns allen am Herzen lien die uns
wichtig waren er hat eher den Macher
rausgekehrt als den Moderator muss er
auch hier an dieser
Stelle ich würde mir aber wünschen dass
er auch als Kanzler öfter mal den Macher
herausstellt und nicht so sehr
moderierend ist Zweifel am Kanzler und
seinem Kurs allerdings kommen weiter von
den ususus Olaf du hast mal gesagt wer
Führung bestellt soll sie bekommen
hiermit bestelle ich sie und wir warten
dringend auf Lieferung heute also sprach
mehr der Genosse Olaf und weniger der
Kanzler Scholz die meisten
Sozialdemokraten hat das überzeugt die
Haushaltskrise ist damit aber nicht
gelöst das Loch im Bundeshaushalt klafft
also weiter was bereits die
Tarifverhandlungen im öffentlichen
Dienst der Länder beeinflusste die
Arbeitgeber fürchten dass der nun klamme
Bund se ine Zuwendungen an die Länder
kürzen könnte die Gewerkschaften dagegen
wollen den öffentlichen Dienst mit
höheren Gehältern attraktiver machen
viele Stellen sind unbesetzt am Mittag
einigten sich die Tarifpartner weitere
Streiks z.B in Krankenhäusern sind damit
abgewendet niikola Albrecht aus
pozdam Schichtdienst und Wochenendarbeit
sind für Straßenmeister Christian
Schmidt und Ronny Zimmer normal 7 Tage
die Woche sorgen sie und ihre Kollegen
rund um die Uhr dafür dass
brandenburgstraßen sicher
sind der Straßenverkehr nimmt zu wir
haben viele Kollegen die eben dicht an
der Fahrbahn ihren Job machen und die
Gefahr jeden Tag mitschwebt Jacqueline
schwarz kümmert sich wiederum darum dass
die Gartenanlagen von Schloss S in
Potsdamm zu jeder Jahreszeit gepflegt
sind ich will auch nicht sagen dass man
schlecht verdient ne also man verdient
schon in einer Stiftung sehr gut ne
aber trotzdem bleibt ja nicht aus dass
trotz sie die Steigerung die
Inflationsrate ist hoch und wie gesagt
Lebensmittel sind teurer alles wird
teurer und obwohl man ja auch ein
bisschen Lebensqualität beugen sie alle
sind Angestellte der Länder und haben
nun monatelang auf höhere Löhne gehofft
oder dafür gestreikt und demonstriert
und werd Chef Frank Werneke hat die
Nächte durch für Sie verhandelt
Erleichterung heute Mittag in Potsdam
doch noch einen Tarifabschluss erreicht
zu haben ab insgesamt ist das ein
Ergebnis mit dem die Beschäftigten der
Länder Anschluss halten es ist ein
Tarifergebnis was die Beschäftigten sich
selbst erkämpft haben und es zeigt
Gewerkschaften wirken die länderkostete
Tarifabschluss 23,9 Milliarden Euro es
sei ein sehr teures Geschenk zum zweiten
Advent natürlich ist der
Kompromiss für uns schwierig und zwar
das ist glaube ich keine Neuigkeit
die Haushalte jetzt auch erst recht nach
dem Karlsruher Urteil nicht nur n auf
der Bundesebene sondern auch auf der
Landesebene und wir spüren die
Auswirkung überall im krisenmodus ist
und so sieht der Abschluss für die
insgesamt 1,1 Millionen Beschäftigten
aus zum Ausgleich der Inflation erhalten
Sie steuerfreie Sonderzahlungen von
insgesamt 3000 € ab November 2024 gibt
es dann 200 € mehr Lohn und ab Februar
2025 soll der Lohn dann um 5,5% steigen
die Laufzeit beträgt 25 Monate
gärtnerinine ist damit zufrieden ich
würde sagen dass wir wirklich einen
super guten Abschluss gemacht haben dass
wir wirklich diese 3000 €
inflationszuschuss bekommen da waren wir
ja alle so ein bisschen im Zweifel ob
dieser Betrag dann noch ausgezahlt wird
und da ist man schon sehr glücklich
drüber wird der Abschluss wie üblich nun
auch auf die Beamtinnen und Beamten
übertragen bekommen mehr als 3 Millionen
Beschäftigte mehr
Geld auf der Weltklimakonferenz in Dubai
steigt an diesem Wochen die Nervosität
die Verhandler unter ihnen die deutsche
Außenministerin Annalena berbock sind
bei der entscheidenden Frage angekommen
nämlich ob diese Konferenz tatsächlich
der Anfang vom Ende fossiler Energien
sein könnte ausgerechnet in einem
Ölstaat mit einem chefverhandler der
selbst Ölmanager ist soll der Ausstieg
aus Kohle Gas und Öl beschlossen
werden unser klimareporter Andreas Stamm
ist für uns in Dubai guten Abend andas
die ölexortierenden Länder haben ja
jetzt offenbar Panik bekommen und sich
in die Verhandlungen eingeschaltet was
heißt das für einen möglichen Ausstieg
aus Öl und
Gas ja das es jetzt wirklich um die
Wurst geht denn bislang konnten sich die
erdölfördernden Staaten ja relativ
entspannt zurücklehnen wenn es um die
Weltklimakonferenzen ging viel heiße
Luft aber nichts was wirklich deren
Geschäftsmodell und deren Reichtum
bedrohen könnte das war der allgemeine
ja Anspruch der da geäußert wurde und
das hat sich jetzt geändert und dafür
würde ich dreiwichtige Gründe nennen
erstens ja die Wissenschaft und die
düsteren Prognosen was den Klimawandel
und die Folgen angeht ja die werden
immer messbarer spürbarer sehbarer
zweitens erneuerbare Energien sind
mittlerweile wettbewerbsfähig in großen
Teilen da ist noch nicht jedes Problem
gelöst aber man hat eben das Gefühl dass
man auch ohne Ölkohle und Gas vorankommt
und dass eben die Menschheit nicht
zurückgeworfen werden würde in die
Steinzeit und dritt da ist dieser
koppräsident der scheint es ist ernster
meint mit diesem Ausstieg als es vielen
der Erdöle exportierenden Staaten lieb
sein könnte und das ist natürlich eine
große Überraschung denn er ist ja auch
in seinem eigentlichen Job der Lenker
eines der größten staatlichen Ölkonzerne
der Welt und das alles zusammen gibt
halt diese Melange aber am Schluss kommt
natürlich das große ABER es gilt das
Einstimmigkeitsprinzip ein Staat kann
alles blockieren die OPEC hat ihre
Mitglieder schon zu einem Veto
aufgefordert also da sind noch
unglaublich viele unabwegbarkeiten aber
eins ist zumindest sicher hier werden
jetzt hinter den Kulissen tagelang die
Fetzen fliegen ist mindestens Dienstag
wird noch verhandelt für uns wird Andrea
Stamm das weiter berichten danke nach
Dubai und weil es in Dubai jetzt schon
3:30r morgens ist haben wir das Gespräch
am Abend aufgezeichnet hier geht's
weiter mit den Nachrichten und mit Heinz
Wolf nach dem Veto der USA gestern am
späten Abend gegen eine un
enstillstandsresolution hat Israel
seinen Militäreinsatz im Gazastreifen
fortgesetzt die Hamas erklärte sie habe
Israel weiter mit Raketen beschossen die
Versorgung der Menschen im
gaserastreifen steht nach Angaben von
Hilfsorganisationen vor dem Kollaps der
Vizedirektor des Welternährungsprogramms
sprach von einer unhaltbaren
Situation Papst franziskus hat zwei neue
deutsche Erzbischöfe ernannt für die
wakanten erzdiözesen P und Bamberg herwi
Gössel übernimmt die Leitung des
Erzbistums Bamberg wo er bislang
weibbischof war und der bisherige
Mainzer weibbischof Udo Benz wird
künftig das Erzbistum Pader born
leiten in der EU soll der Einsatz von
künstlicher Intelligenz mit
weitreichenden Vorgaben reguliert werden
und damit werde die EU so hieß es aus
der Kommission weltweit zum Vorreiter
das Gesetz sieht unter anderem vor die
Kennzeichnung von KI Inhalten bei
besonders risikoreichen Anwendungen die
letzte Kontrolle durch Menschen und
verboten wird unter anderem massenhaftes
Auslesen von gesichtsbildern aus dem
Netz in diesem Jahr ist alles anders
beim jüdischen Lichterfest hanuka der
Terrorangriff der Hamas auf Israel hat
auch das Leben jüdischer Gemeinden in
Deutschland verändert in Berlin kam der
Kanzler demonstrativ zum Brandenburger
Tor um zusammen mit der jüdischenem em
die erste Kerze des hanuka Leuchters zu
entzünden aber wie geht es Jüdinnen und
Juden abseits des politischen
Scheinwerferlichts Petra Otto zeigt uns
was Stuttgart unternimmt damit Juden
sich sicher fühlen
können Licht verbreiten als Zeichen der
Freiheit so dass alle es sehen der
Brauch beim jüdischen chanukar Fest
mitten auf dem Stuttgarter Schlossplatz
steht der Leuchter die jüdische Gemeinde
traut sich raus jetzt erst recht wenn
Terroristen versuchen uns Angst zu
machen dann W machen wir das zum Trotz
ich finde in Stuttgart sind wir sicher
wir wissen dass die Polizei da ist um
uns zu beschützen wenn irgendwas ist
dann kommen wir zusammen reden
miteinander miteinander reden das
Schlüsselwort sie kennen und sie
vertrauen sich in badenwürtemberg gab es
den ersten
landesantisemitismus beauftragten es
gibt Anlaufstellen für jüdische Menschen
zur Zeit bewacht die die Polizei die
Stuttgarter Synagoge rund um die Uhr und
was hinter den gesicherten Mauern
stattfindet das Lernen polizeizubis vom
polizeiabbiner Lehrstunde übers Judentum
und ich möchte vermitteln dass ist ganz
normal eine Synagoge zu besuchen dass
die Polizisten sollen keine hmungen
haben und sollen mehr verstehen von
jüdischem Leben weil sie stehen vor
Synagogen Antisemitismus bekämpfen das
heißt für Polizistinnen und Polizisten
auch präsent zu sein bei Demonstrationen
proästin
in Mannheim 250 Polizeikräfte 1000
demonstrierende aber oberstes Gebot auch
hier miteinander reden Transparenz
Offenheit schon im Vorfeld man spricht
über die Zeiten und über den aufzugsweg
und ganz konkret hier vorort bei der
Versammlung gehen wir als Polizei auch
nochmals auf den Versammlungsleiter zu
um einen kurzen drat zu haben und eben
schnell angepasst reagieren zu
können was rufen Sie auf Arabisch was
steht auf ihren Plakaten die Polizei
filmt mögliche Straftaten und sie hat
einen Übersetzer in Zivil mit dabei der
geschuld ist auf antisemitische Symbole
auf verbotenes wie dieses Plakat mit der
Faust wir lassen das Ganze jetzt
dokumentieren und später wird die Person
kontrolliert werden die Demos verliefen
bisher immer friedlich die Strategie der
Polizei scheint aufzugehen in Mannheim
wie in Stuttgart aus dem Hintergrund
stärken so dass sich die jüdischen
Menschen nicht verstecken müssen und ihr
mehr Licht und mehr sichtbares jüdisches
Leben dann werden
wir auch sicher fühlen und auch sicher
sein so senden Sie während des hananuka
Fests Licht in die Welt als Zeichen für
Freiheit für Frieden und
Toleranz in Berlin heute abend
Verleihung des europäischen Filmpreises
den für die beste Darstellerin hat
Sandra Hüller gewonnen für ihre Rolle im
Drama anatom eines falls das auch als
bester Film ausgezeichnet
wurde und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
Samstag sie lauten wie immer ohne Gewehr
16 21 30 38 42 38 Superzahl 9 und
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotte.zfde und im ZDF Text auf Seite
556 jetzt noch die Wetteraussichten am
Sonntag gibt es im Süden etwas Sonne
bleibt es meist trüb und es regnet
zeitweise die Höchsttemperatur liegt
zwischen 4° in vorpaumn und 11° am
oberrein die neue Woche beginnt sehr
mild und windig die Sonne zeigt sich
kaum dafür regnet es oft und vor allem
im Süden ergiebig im Schwarzwald und an
den Alpen droht
Hochwasser das war's von uns hier geht's
jetzt weiter mit dem Aktuellen
Sportstudio Nationalspieler Leon
Goretzka vom FC Bayern ist zu Gast und
wird sich vermutlich wird vermutlich ein
paar unangenehme Fragen zum heutigen
Spiel beantworten müssen und um 055 Uhr
gibt's dann die nächste heute Express
das war's von uns uns gibt's morgen
wieder schönen Abend
[Musik]
tschüss